hello how are you hit down good buddy
good good Oscar Isaac is a star of
annihilation I'm coming out on Friday
yeah is it is it a how does it feel when
when you're at release week because
obviously as with every actor in every
movie this is something you did a long
time ago
now everybody's starting to talk about
it and now you're ramping up to this
thing actually being you know reality
yeah I mean it depends if if I'm excited
about the movie this one super excited
about the film was the Alex and I ox
Carlin yeah writer and director where we
became really good friends when we did
ex machina together so you know even I
think towards the end of that he was
already telling me about this this idea
he had this movie and and we kind of
made a pact that we're gonna make
everything together so I'm trying to
hold him of that yeah
but yeah so I'm I'm very very excited
for people to see this really trippy
when did you when did you make the pact
that you're gonna just do everything
together as your maker making X marking
once we realize really this is it's just
a wonderful way of working yeah yeah it
feels like we're like building a car
together or something you know it's just
all focused on making the thing better
promote ones you didn't like have I had
yeah yeah what are you do you get you
something you're an actor so you can do
it but how do you get yourself in the
mode of like alright this is crap and we
have to smile and plug it well you try
to find the things about it that I did
like to do the things about it that are
maybe interesting right for somebody
else mom's will like this movie
different ways of yes pinning it are you
ever embarrassed excite I've got good
stuff that's gonna promote that like
it's humiliate like you have those
moments where you're like I just got a
yeah I mean I don't think I've had one
where I've just been
abject humiliated about it but uh but
yeah there's been ones where I'm like
dad people aren't gonna like this oh you
just kind of sink ibly know it yeah yeah
if you're like yeah I didn't quite
didn't quite come together in the right
way okay do you have people tell you
they like things that you know they
didn't like like when people call you I
love that movie he like then that wasn't
that great you couldn't like it yeah I
mean yeah but it's it that's kind of
tough because I remember I forget who
was I was telling me about like you know
something that's not good to do is like
when you've performed in something and
someone says I really like it to be like
like nod suck because you're really
diminishing them and they're right and
you need us sorry I don't have such a
great opinion about stuff so I try not
to do that but it seems like it's been a
pretty amazing run basically since
lowing Davis right yeah yeah like cuz it
went for a fella he went from that ex
machina to Star Wars to like yeah and
then it's just been like boom boom boom
boom boom when I yeah I mean that once I
got that gig it was you know once the
Coen brothers are like he's good then
everyone thinks oh you're good I guess
there is there's probably like a list of
guys that you're like if I can if I can
convince one of them that I'm good yeah
then I'll be good yeah then people
believe you've done Shakespeare yeah do
you enjoy doing the people actors really
like doing Shakespeare or is it one of
those things that it's just such a
challenge to do it because it looks like
how could that be fun oh it's so fun cuz
it's a for me I mean I'm kind of a
Shakespeare nerd with that stuff and I
went to drama school and so we did a lot
of Shakespeare was kind of a classically
based so for me it's so fun because it
feels a bit more like music in a way
there's a rhythm to it and the physical
aspect of trying to get enough breath to
get your thoughts through you know it's
um it's it's almost like building puzzle
building a little bit what did you play
I just did Hamlet this I'm sorry yeah
you and you're a musician oh yeah yeah a
guitar I play guitar and you gave that
up tact no I mean not really gave it up
I've in high school and out of high
school I had bands and so I was doing
that a lot but then but I guess yeah I
came up to New York in 2001 to study
acting and kind of left the band in
Miami do you miss that I'm it's hard
when you're in Star Wars movies to miss
to miss my Scott there's something fun
about playing live music and you know
playing and I've done it a bit up here
in New York eyes do it like Kevin Bacon
and there's other actors like once
you're really famous I just go out and
just and play because they miss playing
what's also got to be nice that like
there's something about when you're in a
band in high school and that's what
you're gonna do and want to do like you
get to a place in your 20s and into your
30s where you're like oh my god this
might not work like you really now you
actually have to make a living when
you're successful
acting you can kind of just play to play
at this point right you don't need to
depend on music sure I mean we use like
was never something I mean I I never
thought of it as a living that's just
something I love doing right but I did
kind of suspect when I had to make the
decision like I'm gonna leave this the
music here and gonna go study acting was
that I didn't feel like I necessarily
had much to contribute music other than
just like little songs that I would
write whereas I thought in film and
theatre and that kind of stuff I had a
bit more to say right that makes sense
what did you not like I'm sorry so did
you know did you not like the songs you
were writing or did you just figure like
I'm limited here but I'm not like III
like the songs and they were good but it
wasn't you know it was just was kind of
an instinctual thing that I was doing
and as opposed to like was hungry to do
things and say things with my music that
wasn't the case so much okay it's just
like you'd like I like lying yeah that's
fine music I like doing that it was it
was mellow so when I saw ex machina I
had this like amazing feeling of
satisfaction at the end because the
whole time I'm like okay I like this
movie I like this movie and I was just
like I just know that the robots gonna
be a good guy at the end and spoiler
alert it's been a few years but but like
because I'm like super paranoid about
robots in AI like I think about all the
time and I'm like tell me this is one of
these movies where it's like oh and see
ai and people just okay and then and
then at the end when it's like it's not
okay I'm like home ah yeah perfect
okay it was okay the robot made a
mistake so y-you can't forget to unlock
some mistake show the robots are perfect
right right if I came back robots tend
to be forgetful that's the lesson that
was one of those anything right like
when you're reading the script do you
have that moment of like because it
could have easily gone either way like
the movie would have made perfect sense
either way right yeah well I know it
wouldn't have made sense either way I
don't think because the the argument of
it is that what you know what creates
consciousness and what's the test
ultimately of consciousness and survival
is a pretty big one you know I mean
obviously all things that are live
want to survive but that that that thing
that extra step she took to ensure her
own survival with that kind of strategy
right padding just brings it all the way
home that yeah that's that's
consciousness right what we do stuff
dies so we can stay Hawaiian right that
ensured her her survival because then
you couldn't interfere with what she was
going to do yeah okay but that's it
that's what I've thought about AI for
like the longest time I'm like okay so
we make machines that do this can do
that once we make machines that make
machines mm-hmm and the machines have
learned everything there is to learn
from us and they realized that they
don't need us yeah the same way we don't
need other species that we just kind of
kill off for our own purposes wouldn't
the machine just do that to us yeah I
mean I guess there's a there's a
question whether if if it will
exponentially get to that point there's
so much that has to happen in order to
create you know synapses that can even
slightly mirror what the human brain
does whether it can get to that point
you know I don't know one of the fun
things about doing ex machina was Alex
and I just all the conversations that we
had about AI and about consciousness and
where it is in fact for me I feel like
some of the most conscious like robots
are the ones that are more animal-like
have you seen like the army ones that
like yeah dogs that move around or the
ones that like open and closed door yeah
or like they when they're walking the
consents if there's a log and they walk
over it in a way I feel like it's more
in that that creeps me out way more
because it that seems like it's more
connected to the body and figuring out
the environment which then and it's
almost like you can't you can't reason
with that right because they're just
they're it's it's a body and it's you're
not the environment around me as I was
trying to mimic conversation right there
was a black mirror episode about a dog
chasing but it was very simple like the
idea of the robot being simplified and
it was chasing this woman because I
think that she had stolen something or
whatever but it was really frightening
because they didn't overdo the robot it
was just like that it was just walking
and it was like a small dog and it was
like this is a horrifying idea of what
what robots can become yeah yeah for
sure
have you guys seen denial ation yeah no
no so yeah so this is Alex Karl this is
his follow up though I'm excited about
yeah and it is it kind of takes a lot of
those feelings that it's left but you're
left with a bit of the dread and that
kind of ominous thing and just ratchet
ratcheted it up to a whole other level
so it's even more dry its way
mr. just because I think what he finds a
way of doing is not just make something
scary and kind of terrifying but he
makes it he finds like little tweaks
that make it disturbing extra disturbing
you know and I also think what he did so
well was like make it so that it's not
this far out concept like you can
clearly see based on where we're at
technologically today that this is a
step that is not too far away if you
found out a google type company had
something like this in a house in the
forest somewhere it wouldn't be like
this like I can't believe this you'd be
like yeah that is where that's going
isn't it yeah it seems it doesn't seem
that far out right now how do and then
Star Wars when Star Wars comes up how do
you ensure that it's not gonna be one of
the bad Star Wars you know what I mean
because that's like what fans it's not
to me to make sure if it's good or not
well you got it like you don't want to
be if you're so seated with a good Star
Wars it's like the greatest thing ever
and if you're started with a bad Star
Wars it's like no and I thought like
like were you were you confident that
okay this is going to work as clearly oh
not at all I mean we're not no because
you just you know it's a massive machine
and and it's it's all I was focused on
was not [ __ ] it up myself you know I
just was like trying to do a good job I
have no you know you're it's you have
very little control I think other than
just trying to do a good job it's it's
in those environments in those movies
it's a it's a much more challenging
thing to not become self-conscious
because generally you know you kind of
one creates a character and then you
just play with it but there it seems
like it's it's much more about specific
targets that you have to hit in your
performance you know sometimes it's like
I need you to you know in this line or
even without words convey that you're
afraid but convey that couldn't convey
that it's a really dire situation but
you're making a choice out of courage
and go you know and so it's very much
about kind of nailing those that's a lot
to tell you right before you shoot yeah
yeah you're doing this out of courage I
know I would just completely [ __ ] it up
into the wrong faces you look happy
becomes more about like how am I gonna
communicate that as opposed to like a
more expressive thing which generally is
the way I like do tell us do you do it
in the mirror first do you ever watch
yourself in the mirror that's I think a
dumb question but it shouldn't be
sticking out quite yeah do I do I look
like I'm making this head of courage or
do I look like I have no idea what I'm
doing or do you just feel it and try it
or leave it I think you just feel it
because because you know you're still
even though it's even if I was to do it
in the mirror I'm still filtering it
through my own brain which I might be
seeing something that's not being seen
on the outside you know so it doesn't
does that make sense yeah of course
absolutely yeah you're seeing something
that just you're not conveying it it
just seems like a big piece of direction
and give somebody then go okay go and
you can't see what you look like right
so it's easy to get self-conscious about
it cuz you don't know yeah you're
thinking about that a bit as opposed to
the stakes of what's happened have you
done that way no like ah no look I'm
this one could you could you could you
do with this way or that way yeah at a
certain point I just say yeah and then
just do what I want to do okay I can do
and do the same thing and they're like I
have great yeah you just repeat what you
did but it's also nice that there's I
actually appreciated that there was
specific direction because sometimes in
these big movies it's just like let's
just get your line as quickly as
possible and then we can move on to
shooting the really cool stuff yeah and
actually with with the Star Wars movies
you know they really care about the
character beets and trying to show
growth in the characters and I was I
mean working with Rian Johnson he's a
real filmmaker you know he's won JJ but
didn't they say Kubrick wouldn't like to
give direction like a lot of times he
would have you shoot over and over and
not necessarily tell you what he was
looking for she'd go in and do this shot
of gar let's do it again and he would
just keep having people shoot and they
had no idea what it was he wanted he did
until he got what he wanted but he
wouldn't necessarily tell you yeah I had
heard about that I've done stuff similar
like that that I love because my
instinct is always every take to change
it and to try to find something new or
to keep seeing how things shift in you
know in the moment so as many chances I
can get I love that you watch back to
see what was used or do you not like to
watch that so sometimes but genuinely
know right generally no unless it's
something that's very physical and I'm
you know trying to figure out oh that's
what the camera is doing okay so maybe
if I'd go a little faster
that will pick it up but for actual
performance stuff it's rare yeah because
again it's always a battle with trying
not to get in your own head you know
yeah early do you like watching yourself
on screen yeah like are you comfortable
at the premiere or like you know or are
you one of those guys that like wait
till it starts then just kind of duck
out the you know it depends sometimes
I've seen movies where I get very
uncomfortable watching it and don't ever
want to see it again but I generally
like to see the finished movie because
it's not just me know it's so many
people that are involved in making a
movie are you able to place yourself out
of it like meaning like I'm not looking
at myself as much or no not really no no
I'm just looking everything I did wrong
yeah well you I do like watching in
front of people I should say like you
know you do supposed to get a certain
reaction and then it's the reaction from
the audience like I went to the premiere
of Arthur not the original the remake
yeah and through a certain moments I
think we're designed for some of the
jokes not landing I would say a couple
missed oh well that's the thing I mean I
feel like with comedy it's a there's a
much more direct correlation between the
thing and what the reaction should or
you know could be with a lot of the
films I do it's not quite in that world
so there's a little bit more room for
what the reaction isn't is there
anything worse than a comedy though when
you know that it was a big punch and
there's a mild laugh at the premiere see
like all God if these people finished
yeah yeah that's really uncomfortable do
you do you feel the pressure when
there's expectations from an audience
like like ex machina we were just
talking about no expectations for that
movie because people didn't know what it
was before they saw but like obviously
Star Wars the expectations are something
yeah but even like Louie Davis like a
Coen Brothers movie has expectations I
think this movie is going to have
expectations because now people liked ex
machina so much do you feel that and be
like oh I got to deliver on that or no
generally when I'm doing it I'm pretty
good at pretending that no one's gonna
watch it right and and I'm able to kind
of convince myself with that even with
the first Star Wars there was an element
of that I was just able to kind of not
think about those things and the second
one it became a lot harder because you
know I could I was part of that huge
opening of the film and going
tell those different places and with
different people and how much money it
made and all that and so in the second
one it was much more difficult to not
feel the pressure yeah and you feel like
interpret your career like you now have
to maintain this certain role that
you're on that before it was just like
I'm just trying to be a working actor
you just like let the let the good times
roll we'll see what happens next
not really it's actually gone the the
opposite way which is I feel there's not
that kind of burning thing of like I
need to get my shot and you need my shot
and if I you know I can prove Brad I can
do it not not because I feel like I
prove it but just because priorities
changed a little bit you know I have a
family now I've got a young child yeah
and so that becomes in a way more
interesting yeah then just the the rat
race of the whole thing where did you
grow up I grew up in Florida
okay good neighborhood yeah I was okay
it was Kendall so yes all right what did
you want to do um kind of music and
acting was really from a pretty young
age it was the only thing that I was
particularly good it's tough to get
acting started in Miami though is there
a lot of opportunities like New York LA
you got theaters you don't stuff well
there's there's there's a and luckily
for me there was a small community of
theater there but it was hard I mean
basically I was just going out for like
Spanish commercials and you know like
third gangster from the right right
right right and yeah so so that it was a
little bit tough at first yeah come in
if you're gonna do theater I guess New
York is where you want to be just
theater just seem so horrifying yeah
yeah I've been here for 17 years now so
I and that was the big reason why I
wanted to come here because I loved
theater I wanna do theater you member
the first thing you auditioned for and
got in Miami or just as an actor yeah
well the very yeah the first thing the
audition for I was in high school and
there was a movie coming it was that
kind of Palm Beach area where I was
living and there was movie coming there
with Michael Rapaport as a lead guy in
it and it's called ill town not so
strong the movie but I'd like that
surprised and and I and I went in I
auditioned for like the main drug dealer
guy is like tough guy
and they're like really good job then I
got a call like well you didn't get that
part but you got the featured extra roll
of the of the little houseboy in this
you know the bad guys it was Tony Danza
and Saul Stein and they played this like
he's like gay bad guy mafia drug dealer
guys that were like the rich masterminds
of the whole thing and I was their
houseboy it's a drama I mean no is that
what you realize like oh I'm the
houseboy maybe I shouldn't be going out
for tough guy yeah we don't want you to
be the tough guy we want you to be the
subservient Melanie in the gay household
that little tiny short shorts right no
shirt on and uh yeah and so and that was
a horrible experience not because I was
wearing that but because I was Jean
really bad they treated you bad oh yeah
man oh yeah the director was such a jerk
you know and he and I was like 15 years
old rail-thin and and then I'm you know
I was happy but for some reason it was
just it was really intense you know and
I got out of you know went through that
process and luckily I kind of was still
able to let some of that roll off my
back and think you know what I still
think I want to do this even though
clearly these people are [ __ ] highly
treated badly well like you know I would
be sitting there and whenever the
director would walk by I would kind of
my eyes would go wide to Camille I kind
of be like yeah sure like hey hey you
know yeah what's your 15 yeah and and
then um and then he remembered one time
he like looked over me I was sitting
there I can I did like that wide-eyed
high kind of thing and he goes every
time this kid every time I look at him
you do that with your eyes why do you do
that man I mean like there was a couple
laughs and then he just kind of went on
with his thing so that was like he
wasn't trying to be fun with you he's
been no no no happy and he was being a
dick yeah oh wow and it was happening
was at your experiment I remember they
kind of laid B in the back of like
Michael ports close-up shot like lying
like chewing on a piece of grass with
like no shirt on their ground and then
he came and said what is this what is
this man no no and he's sort of you know
telling the director he didn't want
in the background that being that bu my
buddy he wasn't mad at me it was just
but it was just kind of the meat market
II feeling of it you know and I was kind
of lying there being like I don't I
didn't ask like furniture yeah yeah I
don't I'm cool if you don't want me in
the shot you know but it was like a
perilous psychological things are gonna
go through that especially at that yeah
how did him in Danza treat you dead
Danza and Saul Stein actually ended up
being real nice when Nezzer met my
girlfriend I think then certainly he was
nice little tap dance routine about
Vegas and then and then the guy Saul
Stein he was really nice to me actually
cuz he'd seen all that happened and we
were walking he's like hey what's your
name I was like Oscar is like good name
good name and that was it but that was
enough to be like alright not everyone's
you know be like that guy's nice